the man is dead after a shooting and a  crash in the East Valley Metro Police  say it happened last night near 13th in  Stuart detectives tell us the man was  found after he crashed into a parked car  near Eastern and Bonanza around 7 30.  when officers arrived they found that  victim with gunshot wounds he was taken  to UMC where he died Metro says they  believe the shooting is tied to a shot  spawner alert  we believe the this incident is tied to  a shot spotter that we received in the  area of 13th and Mesquite we believe  that is where the actual shooting took  place and that after the shooting took  place our decedon occupied his vehicle  and left that area anyway eastbound on  Bonanza right now very little is known  about a suspect if you have any  information you are asked to call Crime  Stoppers they're at the number on your  screen